hi there my name is katie Morgan and I'm
with the IBM cloud team and today I'm
going to be talking about data migration
so before you can actually start using
the cloud you'll have to first figure
out how you're actually going to get
your data to the cloud in my experience
there are three primary factors that you
should be considering when you're
looking at data transfer methods the
first being the type of workload that
you're moving and the second is how much
data are you moving thirdly how quickly
do you need the transfer to occur so for
large-scale data migrations and by large
I mean terabytes to petabytes worth of
data cloud providers will typically
provide you with a portfolio of options
you know products services that enable
you to move your data from point A to
point B and most of these portfolios
span two primary categories offline
transfer an online transfer for offline
transfer which is great if you're in a
you know remote location or if you're in
a place where high-speed connections
just are unavailable or are just cost
prohibitive to you offline transfer
options are great because they leverage
portable storage devices to move your
data from point A to point B the first
being a customer owned device and what
that looks like is you sending in your
own piece of hardware whether it's a USB
stick external hard drive cd/dvd
something like that to a cloud providers
data center for connection and once that
device is mounted depending on the cloud
provider either you will remotely
control that data transfer or they will
initiate the transfer on your behalf and
once the transfer is complete they'll
ship the device back to you or some
providers actually offer to destroy the
device on your behalf if that's
something that you're interested in so
not a hard and fast rule but we often
recommend a customer owned device
transfer method for workloads that are
10 terabytes or less in size again not a
strict rule but a good at rule of thumb
to go by and for workloads that exceed
that 10 terabyte capacity will often
point people towards provider owned
device
offline transfer options and what that
really looks like is your cloud provider
shipping you a large capacity portable
storage device to your location for you
to put your data onto it and then
immediately send back to the cloud
providers data center once it gets back
to that cloud provider they're going to
immediately offload your data from that
device and into your target cloud
environment once the transfer is
complete absolutely go free and access
your data while the cloud provider will
securely wipe that device of your data
and immediately return the device to
inventory for reuse for the next
customer so similar to the customer own
device we use this as the standard
benchmark for capacities when using a
provider own device and that's really
tens of terabytes to hundreds depends on
the cloud provider that you're working
with some of the devices actually span
from single terabytes and capacity all
the way up to a petabyte scale just
depends on who you're working with and
what you're trying to do and finally if
you're really not looking for an offline
transfer you want to transfer data over
the network or you're really looking for
that high-speed technology that's when
you want to consider an online transfer
option you can write custom applications
using high speed transfer libraries or
spit-up
a high speed transfer client at your
location and connect it to the cloud
providers high speed server cluster
something to consider with online
transfer as well as offline as I'm sure
you can tell your network connections
and speeds significantly impact all of
these options but especially the online
transfer if you're thinking that your
transfer time is really going to creep
up into that you know week-long or plus
a duration for a migration you might
want to consider a combination of any of
these offerings or really an offline
transfer the longer that you spend
migrating using over the network options
the longer that it'll take and the
longer or I'm sorry the higher the costs
typically so if you're looking to drive
down costs you definitely want to keep
that in mind and then finally just a
couple things that you should probably
consider
some of these offerings with the
customer own device definitely look at
your cloud providers webpage they'll do
a good job of outlining any hardware
specifications or requirements so that
you are you know able to send a device
that's actually compatible with what
they're looking for for the provider own
device area you definitely want to look
at their web pages and see any features
and benefits that the varying devices
and capacities will offer the size of
your workload will really depend on or
I'm sorry will really determine what
capacity you're looking for in terms of
device and then extra bells and whistles
like GPS tracking or edge computing
definitely look and see if any of those
piqued interest and see if the device
models match thanks for watching this
video on data migration if you have any
questions feel free to drop us a line
below and if you like this video and
want to see more like and subscribe to
our Channel and be on the lookout for
more videos just like this